it's a quick exactly the question is why
do you need a law and I would like I do
what your Chancellor said I want to put
it absolutely beyond doubt that you know
I really want hard working people in our
country who work every hour who want to
have a better future for themselves and
their families I that want them to know
that we're not going to put up v80 or
national insurance or income tax because
we know we can make the remaining
savings without having to attack their
wallets that's the pleasure they get
when when Alice stood when Alistair
Darling tried the same thing your
Chancellor said no other Chancellor in
the long history of the office has felt
the need to pass a law in order to
convince people he has the political
will to implement his own budget why do
you suddenly need to pause and I always
have a tie which could have changed
anyways we know it was at a dropper when
the budget deficit was forecast to be
bigger than the deficit in Greece that's
what we inherited so making that sort of
promised then was meaningless now having
spent five years as prime minister
knowing what needs to be done and let me
let me be clear about what still needs
to be done we've got to save one out of
every hundred pounds the government
spends for each of the next two years
that's the extent of the efficiencies
that are needed and then we can start to
see public spending growing again to
make sure that we go on putting money
into our schools and hospitals and all
the important public services the